welcome to another edition of famous
Fridays where I look at a famous
entrepreneur and help you model the
success to achieve your goals
today's theme is bet on people the
safest bet you can ever make is on
yourself bet on yourself
the second safest bet you can make is on
other people and you need to bet on
people when it feels right you know when
you feel something in your gut you think
this person is gonna do great things we
could do great work together and even if
it doesn't look great on paper even if
there might not be a logical rational
reason to do it it feels like something
great will happen and you can take that
bet and it's surprising how often those
bets work out so my favorite famous
entrepreneur is AP Giannini he's the
founder of Bank of America and he taught
me to take bets on people when the city
he lived in got devastated by a fire and
all the banks were closed he opened up
shop with two wooden barrels and a plank
across it and lent people money to
rebuild their lives based on a handshake
and a look in their eye are you kidding
me a handshake and a look in their eye
can you imagine a banker doing that now
when a young entrepreneur named Walt
Disney came into his office and said I'd
like to create the first-ever full
feature-length cartoon he had been
laughed out of every other bankers
office that you're nuts nobody's gonna
watch a full feature-length cartoon but
AP Giannini even though it made no sense
rationally logically liked Walt Disney
and bet on him and he gave him the money
to fund Snow White and the Seven Dwarfs
which became a huge hit and he continued
to fund Disney's movies and then with
Disney came back and said I want to
create the first theme park around my
movies everyone said it was nuts
you're crazy just stick to the movie
business you're good at that you don't
need a theme park nobody would find him
except AP Giannini who gave him the
money to launch Disneyland
again when Amina
any logical rational sense he was
betting on the person and it's again
surprising how often those bets work out
when you bet on the person even though
it may not make rational sense so start
betting on people believe if you guys
like this video you can support me by
clicking on the link in the description
leave a comment let me know what you
think and click on my face subscribe to
the channel thank you so much I'll see
you soon